all right avi are you ready to go i'm
ready yeah
okay great so let's get started on the
next talk then so our
second speaker was obvi bakerson
um avi's also a very distinguished
uh contributor theory of computer
science has worked in
many many areas and uh he's speaking
today
on are we aging well
and a bit on lower bounds okay
thanks a lot sam and thanks for the
invitation and it's great to be here and
uh with dick
uh who was i'm sure all of you knew was
my postdoc advisor and
had an amazing influence on me and my
research
um yeah so i was going to talk much more
about lower bounds
but uh so i'll explain why
the title um
okay i just need to fix my view here
okay
so this uh you know the scope of the uh
this particular workshop on the 50 years
since that's triability
i just uh to put it in a bit of context
because i'll talk about history
um um i think that well of course we
know
that with during this paper algorithm
started and
was the birth of computer science and of
the theory of computing
and i guess i'll distinguish them and
the breakthrough of the 1970s um
yeah so that lots of great theories
started then
and set up the stage for for us for
complexity theory
and this happened mainly in that decade
that dick talks about quite a bit
uh in detail in the mid 60s and mid 70s
well i would say that
i would call it the best of the theory
of computation methodology
what we exercise or call computational
complexity where we had
focus on efficiency on resources like
time and space
reductions and completeness where it's
introduced
classification of problems the pnp
question as we understand it was born
randomness came up the same time and
crypto has its uh you know
and then in the next 50 years uh i think
wonderful things happen so i can already
ask to answer the question in the title
are we aging well i mean
brilliantly well we grew and
became mature and got deeper and broader
and very diverse
uh introducing lots of models and
settings and investigating them
discovering many interconnections
between them
and started collaborating with many
other scientists
other sciences so a lot of
great theories were born and lots of new
challenges
and one would think and in fact it is a
fact that uh you know
lots of confidence would come with that
and it did but uh
somehow there were also some crisis and
uh
that that um as i was started preparing
the talk a week ago somebody sent me a
uh you know maybe it was a mistake to
read this very long
um exchange in a
chat that had to do initially with some
stock forks
rejection but got into discussion of
real issues
that people are feeling about the
subject of theory
so i decided to investigate how to talk
to that so
here are questions that came up in this
uh i'm
you know making them general it's theory
relevance to practice
asymptotic bounds useful at all the
models need real-world motivation
should we focus on problems and
techniques is people send me any goods
as a problem goal for the field which
problems are important given the
diversity or you know how can we tell
you know given so many different areas
are we mathematicians or computer
scientists identity crisis
a lot of the issues that came up and the
points were made were very specific
about you know is
this algorithm goes or is this model
motivated and so on
and this sort of reminded me of this uh
very ancient buddhist fable
that many of you probably know about the
blind people who are trying to
uh understand this huge beast and just
by feeling some part of it and
trying to guess what it is or
in this case maybe complain about uh
part of the whole and uh
i think that uh you know why one way to
answer many of these existential issues
is just uh
basically talk about this elephant in
the room i mean to me i look at
it and it's just magnificent uh
but you know some people
don't necessarily feel that or don't
maybe see the whole picture and i think
if they don't
or if anybody doesn't then it's our
fault
our fault as educators i mean i mean
talk i mean
educate i think that the um
this field has been great about doing
research it's also it's been great about
teaching
uh students you know the techniques the
algorithms that the analysis tools and
so on but i think
not enough is done about the greater
mission about the whole about the
achievements the history the impacts the
challenges
um standing high up and uh
i think well one has to start from the
highest
you know point of view or the most
significant bit
and i would say this is it so uh i think
we have to realize that that's
uh the ballpark we are playing at that's
what theory of confusing is about
we are just the the youngest member in
this family of uh
grand theories that have very very long
term
intellectually deep goals um
some live thousands of years some just
several centuries and we are
you know maybe 50 or 80 years old but
that's
that's all we are just beginning uh
this intellectual goal uh goals they've
produced and studying them
produced lots of
results of all kinds they've also
produced
many many practical applications
but i must tell you i mean in general we
should learn from these
order fields i don't see anybody coming
to
my colleagues in the physics or any
physics department
telling them to stop investigating black
holes or
particle physics just because they need
help with
fixing the light bulb or maybe even
creating
some particular um
[Music]
low energy capacities capacitors or
you know practical important practical
problems that may
uh heat our houses better but you know
nobody that demands that they stop their
theoretical investigation
uh i'm going to be very brief in
summarizing
some of the things we've done i can
believe both because i have no time and
because lots of what i'll say summarize
the
you know it's detailed in this book
which is free that i
wrote about a year ago published about a
year ago
so i'll be i'll be quite brief in this
uh
pep talk or addressing some of the
issues that i mentioned
um first has to do with the fact that
we are not only the younger child in the
in this
set of you know grand theory uh we are
also
very connected to the others and this
goal there understanding the laws of
computation
uh we have to understand or we know in
fact it's evident that
computation is everywhere so when we are
studying computation it's not
just time and it's not just on computers
i mean we are studying
of course we are studying them but we
are studying computers in networks
neurons in the brain atoms in matter
cells in living tissue and you can read
prices on market
friends of facebook
computation happens in all of them and
what we have to add to this is a
methodology that i talked about before
that we developed
in this 50 years of work and
is pretty unique to us it's very
different than physics and math and
biology
the ideas of classification and
reduction and
resources and computational modelling
are essential now modeling
one of the issues that came up with
practicality of
models there are two stories
i can tell i mean one uh is that uh
yar was once asked in the early days
after he introduces
introduce communication complexity
whether it's realistic
and it should be studied and this is a
you know his reaction was sort of
automatic of course
it's so basic we know of course 50 years
later what it
did the other is that often
you know it's important to just follow
your
gut and you know if you study bacteria
in petri dish and you believe
that maybe you should first study
quantum bacteria and the dish has to be
hyperbolic then
you know do it because
we have to i think uh of course
intellectual integrity is always
important in science but that may be
necessary and maybe i'll give you an
example if i have time anyway
discovering these laws is a great
challenge and great responsibility
and that's what we've done and that's
what we continue to do
so let me uh talk a bit about it
uh but of course studying with the you
know scientific questions computational
in science questions is what created
these amazing connections with the
with all these sciences that they have
grown
beautifully uh but the picture also
wants to stress that we are an
independent
discipline i mean we in order to
facilitate these connections and
you know do them better we should we are
an independent major academic discipline
and this includes
the connection to masters then to
computer science
uh we do it
you know across these errors our ideas
people
many of our greatest you know theories
as many of you know i mean in fact dick
went and uh
to do five years of biology uh
you know just took time off computer
science and worked with biologists
and many other examples the courses
fields are well known
um another issue again with respect with
computer science and mathematics is this
identity crisis
i used to you know giving talks like
this uh
you know saying that it has been
extremely lucky for our field
to have parents with so different genes
i mean computer science being young and
patient
with math is older than patient uh you
know
one you know grounded in practice and
demands
uh you know modeling of real life things
and
the other demands beauty aesthetics
abstraction
and uh measuring things here by
performance and thereby illegal i think
the influence of this total set of genes
on
our field and its growth has been
tremendous
just uh fantastic now it seems like
it can create identity crisis of the
type are we mathematicians or
computer scientists and i think everyone
is what they choose to be or what they
what they do best but it's good to
remember that we are not kids anymore i
mean
we go independent of our parents as well
so over these years i think the
as i mentioned the field has created i'm
not going to
go over this this is there um
you know lots of amazing uh theories in
so many different areas
and i think that uh sometimes we just
forget this so take it for granted or
just talk about specific results that we
want to teach
um the students as opposed to just
looking back and explaining or going
into some of the
things that are in them even very old
theories contain
amazing intellectual you know results
and understandings and
uh yeah this is maybe with only one page
here's another page i mean you
just take you know that it takes a
semester
or more maybe a year to teach each of
them
and uh not only have they
you know huge deep intellectual content
content but they also you know they are
practical
and you know practical one has to
remember how to measure this you cannot
just talk
take a result and say is it you know the
right constant or the right exponent
already uh
theories first of all i mean everybody
takes this for granted but
everybody in industry technology and all
the practical areas
you know they use the language and tools
to actually discuss
what they are doing that's you know
taken for granted and lots of it was
created in this series
and the other are the many examples i
probably don't have to
go through them or see always predated
and enabled um you know technology is in
billions and billions that
and huge changes is in society i mean of
course crypto and quantum computing is
just uh
you know one one example but you know
there are so many
um i
decided against my uh
i often feel that it's wrong to justify
uh
theory by giving practical applications
really practical and
you know conceptual ideas and specific
algorithms which
really change industry uh but anyway i
didn't make a list i mean
you know probably not going to go over
this either
but you just have to imagine what the
you know programming
languages would have been without the
linear time pass parcel of
note or with what text processing would
have been without a linear time
string matching algorithm or of course
dick mentioned the linear programs
and uh what computer server farms
the hundreds of millions that are saved
by
the
one algorithm whose impact on the world
was
unbelievable but even algorithms like
shaw
who cannot be implemented which cannot
be implemented there is no machine here
created you know in an industry and a
huge developed
development of understanding quantum
systems
just by the you know giving this
algorithm
and you know the minhash algorithm of
border that
underlies probably all of the redundancy
elimination in all big data applications
and people forget sometimes that deep
learning and in general
you know lots of convex programming
wouldn't exist if leibniz didn't
discover the chain rule and allowed us
to uh compute gradients in linear time
as opposed to quadratic time
what is called now the back propagation
algorithm and so on there
are so many examples and uh you know
just
i think people sometimes forget them
okay
uh yeah you know this is basically what
we
celebrate and talk quite a bit
about this and i think again people uh
you know of course it had a very
concrete technical
meaning when we started with it
but we understand it much better today
it means
much more i mean of course that's a
classical
you know intellectual question of asking
is is it possible that searching for
something is as
easy as checking and you go up and uh
it's more or less the question is
whether we can know everything we want
to know
we can only hope to want to know
something we can check right
uh can creativity researching parts you
know be automatic consider improving be
automated can you know modeling by
scientists
you know automation and it leads to the
question
is are there hard problems at all i mean
maybe everything is easy
not just in polynomial time in any in
any complexity measure in any model i
mean it's possible that
you know there are so many more
algorithms that we know today
we can seem to find out problems i'll go
back to that
but these issues you know picking on the
p
versus empty question like oh worst case
why worst case uh you know it's
i find it's funny it's like to
understand that to start
or why um why polynomial
why not linear time one has to realize
that when you are first faced with an
exponential gap
you know you first maybe have to make it
a polynomial graph and then you make it
a quadratic there and then and
and so on to uncover structure you have
to
pick the right resolution to start
obviously
but today i i feel previously mp is just
the call to understand the laws of
computation wherever they are
that's that's what it is that's the
meaning of the question to me
i had this uh example that i promised
may i'll just mention it
uh i gave last week against
coincidentally i talked about this uh
recent breakthrough because i just
wanted to explain the wonders of the
methodology of the theory of computation
this was mathematicians
but i'm sure all of you heard about mip
style equals
which you know got a lot of attention
because of its impact on on
physics and mathematics it resolves all
sorts of uh
problems and conjectures they will talk
you know
and this is a result uh clearly in
computational complexity
so uh yeah i mean i think
somehow it's an amazing story of course
and
what i've talked in an hour i will not
go
now into in a minute but it's sort of an
evolution that was forced by our
methodology
i have the here the the timeline i'm
again not going to go through it but
uh tweeting meandering story of trying
to understand the
relative power of person algorithms
which
we are still trying to do and people's
mp is one
of the many incarnations of this but
there are many other incarnations
that were introduced because of
randomness because of quantumness
that we do understand and this
understanding not only
is important to us but as you see it's
important to other fields
okay let me go back to this and
uh to the fact that we don't know how to
prove it and how to prove low balance
so now i want to switch to what i really
meant to talk about so good i took 20
minutes and now i can talk
less than 20 minutes uh i want to talk
about low bounds
and i want to talk about low bounce
through algorithms
and i think maybe i don't know
a single example of an explicit low
bound that is not derived by
an algorithm anyway the search for low
bounds
through algorithms is a win-win
situation because
you know discovering the algorithms is
not so bad
you know there is one joke that we don't
discover lower bounds because they are
only algorithms
but sometimes you can use algorithms to
prove lower bounds so there are simple
examples i mean
many of you know there are unconditional
uh
results first of all i mean dick
mentioned out of my
stomach the time hierarchy it's proved
that p
is different than exponential time say
by diagonalization by an algorithm
another
simulation it's an algorithm more
sophisticated by
low degree approximation has both proved
this famous result that
mc1
[Music]
cannot be done with icc or circuit and
parity let's say majority cannot be done
much more sophisticated but again using
algorithms uh
using not real thought algorithms
derived from low degree approximation
williams pulled his famous result that
ncp and non-deterministic exponential
time cannot be done
in acc 0 which you call the
annoying complexity class i really love
it
and of course we also have uh we have
conditional results where
algorithms implied over if you want to
improve that monies term maybe prove
that
np is different than exponential time
it's really easy you just have to give
an algorithm
for such right polynomial time algorithm
for start to do it
so that's a triviality but you can get
to the same conclusion
for much weaker assumptions or seemingly
weaker assumptions let's say
you can get it from non-uniform
algorithms
also implying a uniform conclusion
maybe we can do that or
my favorites and what i want to talk
about is this
absolutely amazing paper of
cabanas in palliative on
with the following statement so the
polynomial identity testing
problem that i'll mention next but i'm
sure
many of you know if it has a
deterministic polynomial time algorithm
then basically you separate the
arithmetic analogues of
p and np so of course for people who
haven't seen it's sort of amazing
it's a concrete problem you give it an
algorithm
and you have proved the lower bound and
not just the lower boundary you know
one of our priciest goals
so if you don't know it it's not so
complicated it's beautiful
but let's explore it let's prove this
algorithm or at least try to so
what is the what's the pid problem
um think of a you know field and
variables
in it and the ring of polynomials and
we are looking at the following type of
polynomial
uh the terminal so determinant of what
the input uh you should think of it as a
couple of matrices
and matrices each of them and by n
and you think of them as defining a
symbolic matrix
the sum a i x i so it's really an unbind
matrix
uh in which every entry is a linear form
in this virus
and then you take the determinant and
ask whether it's identically zero
this is a then you say yes otherwise you
say no that's the class bit
and okay so this is a
this is the problem if you have a
deterministic polynomial time algorithm
for this
then you've separated vp and vmp it's
sort of
stunning uh
it moves you know in a brilliant you
know vision
uh asked this question uh 50 years ago
and uh we still don't know the answer i
mean if we had it really we have a
fantastic law one right uh
it's very easy to see at the you know
this high time of uh probabilistic
algorithms
noted that it has a simple probabilistic
algorithm you basically
plug random small integers to the
variables and compute the numeric
determinants right
symbolic determinant has exponentially
many terms but the numeric determinants
you just
do gaussian elimination so
uh it has a very fast randomized
polynomial time algorithm which really
means and that's
very dear to me that this question of
low bounds is also
a question of the randomization i mean i
would say
lower bounds and the randomization of
the
topics i spent most of my uh
career on or thinking time on
so it's a randomization question uh
we can't solve it so as we do
in math and science and theory we just
you know try somewhat easier problems
and see whether we can develop
techniques for them
so one thing we looked at very
inadvertently
uh got into it and i will not tell you
how
the following problem uh it looks
exactly the same i give you a couple of
m matrices then by n
but i asked you that to compute the
determinant
of this matrix so now it's uh
some ai tensor x i also the x i is a
matrix of variables and
which is m by m so it's a very similar
problem
right i mean it's uh when you open this
sensor thing up it's basically your
computing the determinant of n squared
band squared
matrix of linear forms looks exactly the
same
i put starter because it's actually a
star i put in
my p star it's sort of a quantum version
of the original or non-community version
of the original
and yeah maybe you should wonder a
second
which problem you think is harder
although because of time let me answer
you
uh it's also obvious uh yeah so it's an
easier problem this
uh quantum version is an easier problem
this is
sort of a simple direct reduction which
is more or less what i said
a minute ago so it's an easier problem
so maybe we can solve this one
and indeed we can i mean that's uh
what we did about five years ago and
actually got me to spend
most of my time on this type of
questions and techniques in the past
five years so
the first message is this problem which
is a sub problem of the problem we
really want to solve
has a deterministic polynomial time
algorithm the second thing which is even
more amazing
is the way what this algorithm looks
like i mean it's an algebraic problem
right but actually the and i'll say more
about it it's sort of a
gradient descent so now it seems like
maybe we can access
by cabanas in pariato again can access
this big problem permanent versus
determinant of vp versus vmp
beyond optimization and i still think we
can
so let me talk about this for the last
five or ten minutes ahead
yeah so i thought that uh before this
uh telling you i'll tell you about uh
some of the applications that this
result has i mean it's a result in some
conversational or algebraic complexity
every type of thing i mean it's sort of
stunning to me even though i know uh
i know how and why things happen that
it's connected
to so many things i mean as part of
proving this
we we realize that uh it
solves problems in non-commutative
algebra and in analysis and actually
it's sort of
even stunning that it at the same time
can deal with proving identities and
with proving inequalities
in the case of non-commutative algebra
the type of identity that you want to
uh prove or compute verifies the
you know things like normal formulas
only in non-commutative variables
it turns out yeah okay i'll say
this is hard because unlike the
commutative cases
nested inversions cannot be eliminated
in st in fact it was not known for a
long time whether this problem is
decidable
this caused the world problem for
non-communistic fields
in the inequality side there is a large
family that i would not explain
of inequalities but you know them i mean
whether a product
of whether the integral of a product is
almost a product of
basically of integrals and
whether there are you know equalities
like this uh
special cases of which abound i mean
because ishwar soldier boone minkowski
miss whitney and nelson hyper
contractivity and many others that you
know
are just special cases of this so when i
give you such an inequality you want to
check whether it
hurts or not or what's the optimal
constant that's the
gross complete inequalities and as it
turns out
we we understood really part of uh
the the process of understanding this um
pi st
pi t's question
was understanding these problems and it
turned out that uh
they have this relationship the world
problem is equivalent to it
and the boss complement is even easier
it sits inside and so
they automatically get polynomial time
algorithm
and after our work people discovered
more connections of this very
basic you know simple to state pid style
beyond what
you know to other areas you wouldn't
imagine or related
the really beautiful results in
statistics resolving
long-term questions on maximum
likelihood estimation
in matrix and tensor normal models
and to an estimation this about
elliptical distributions
and an operator theory you know just
recently resolved the person problem
that was open for 25 or 30 years in this
field just using
many of these techniques both structural
results and algorithms follow and there
are many more i i'm not going
to mention it just when we talk about
interconnections in the fields not just
in the field algorithms expose
interconnections between
other fields let's say in math and the
statistics and the quantum information
theory more
but let me just end with talking a
little bit about
what we know about this optimization
problem that comes up so here are the
two problems
uh i want to talk about symmetries in
algebraic varieties
so look at these two problems in both of
them you know just what you are given is
a set of matrices so about n cubed
numbers let's say we are over the
complex numbers because that's where it
makes more sense
um you want the determinant to vanish so
it's it's a bunch of conditions on the
coefficients which are the just
polynomial conditions on these
uh input variables v8
so they are just algebraic varieties
right as the bright varieties are just
simply
solutions to systems of polynomial
equations
so what for what varieties can we
easily test membership so that's that's
a basic question
i somehow implicitly give you such a
variety
and i give you a point in space and i
ask whether it's
in the variety and the understanding
we have is that if this variety
is an alcohol okay what's an alcohol
it's basically something captured by the
symmetries
there's a group of symmetries acting on
this variety
if it's captured by some symmetries of a
nice little
linear group then it supports
an algorithm and algorithm of this
dynamical
types the gradient descent in fact
algorithm only
in some different spaces what we are
used to
not uh you know not euclidean space but
some other curve space
geodesic uh basically the manifold that
describes the group
so the the real reason this algorithm i
told you before
works is that this p i t star this
quantum version of p i t
special case of p i t is an algorithm of
a very simple group action
and we were trying for a couple of years
to uh you know just do it for
extended to uh pit and we failed and
didn't know for a while why but
uh eventually mr macam and i found a
barrier result it's not an alcohol
so you can you know discover properties
about varieties
but it's just a barrier you know maybe
one can extend these techniques
um just to summarize this sort of
point of view i mean this problem of
memberships in
narcons every problem i've shown you in
the previous two slides
are problems of this type and there are
many others i didn't show you
there are just ask about memberships in
in narcon so we have algorithms for that
and this uh
this last paper in the in the series
just develops the basic convex
optimization of this uh
of this type of you know problems and uh
we get new algorithms and we still hope
that maybe that will give us
uh lower bounds but an important message
some important messages one is that you
need some math to
actually analyze these algorithms even
though they are simple to describe
and the symmetry which is uh you know
just
perfect matching is also a an outcome
problem
but when you learn or think about the
perfect matching problem you don't
at least not obviously think about
semester is a good action and so on but
thinking about this this way gives you
new algorithms for
uh problems including perfect match
and for those in the know
it's naturally connected even though it
started very differently
it's connected to the gct geometric
complexity theory of marmalade and
sohoni where they also try to separate
vp and vnp using the environmental
presentation
basically by thinking about them these
classes as
algebraically so there are lots of
connections that i will not discuss
uh and uh lastly let me mention that
just
nalcon's are just the beginning of the
type of questions uh
that this setting of symmetries
suggests i mean it's all part of uh
environment theory and algorithms in
line theory is uh you know
well-developed subjects only that many
of the algorithms use things like global
basis and
techniques like that that require
exponential or doubly exponential time
so it's a
it gives new algorithms for many of
these that are much faster but
also uh you know suggest that uh we
extend them to
other problems like orbit problems all
big problems generalized
narco problem it's just uh here are
examples but anyway
my point is it's a lot of fun
discovering algorithms by trying to pull
robons
um here are examples of you know ob
problems of course
graph isomorphism is an orbit problem
for the symmetric group acting on the
vertices of the graph
that we know um but in this research
paper we we explore
questions of this type um you know will
mouth and
earth ever collide so dynamical systems
look at the orbits of two objects given
initial conditions
or similarly with the cue ball pocket
the red ball eventually if you know how
it starts
and for this audience i thought i'd end
just with the
one consequence of this algorithm that
we developed in this
paper because of course we didn't
invent it it just came out as a special
case of this type of
problem about orbeez so maybe it's an
easy program i don't know i've never
seen it and i
didn't think so it doesn't look so easy
to solve otherwise but
uh let me tell you what the problem is
by the way here the algorithms are
algebraic
not analytic okay so what's the problem
uh uh you have a
graphic bypass size graph maybe it's a
complete bypass doesn't matter and i
give you two sets of integer weights
for the edges maybe the the blue weights
and the red weights
okay and now you look at all perfect
matchings of this graph and what i asked
you
is it the case that every perfect
matching in this graph
has the same total weight on the red
weights
and on the blue weights so is it the
case that
all of them each perfect matching has
the same weight or
this is not the case turns out that this
is
a has a polynomial time algorithm maybe
it can be done in a
simple way but i don't know okay uh
enough so let me uh
[Music]
summarize my time is basically up let me
go back to the
uh thing i started with uh as i said
we've grown
big and diverse and there are some
growing pains that
you know have to be discussed i think
that our enormous successes they
have brought you know lots of growth
there's diversification
influx of amazing young talent i think
it's just
wonderful to watch uh people coming into
our field
uh we want lots of scientific respect
lots of industrial respects lots of
societal respect
i think we are not doing that great or
some
are not doing that great on self-respect
but i hope this will improve
also so i think we should uh
we use everybody i mean uh and uh
thinking about the field uh what
you know how it should run itself i
think it should uh
stay independent of all other fields
including computer science and including
mathematics it's uh
to stay cohesive because of the
amazing interconnections between its
sub-areas and sub-fields that so well
feed each other
i think that because we are growing i
mean we are a young field and have to
learn maybe from
older fields or older disciplines
but not learn everything uh maybe have
to reorganize the way we are working the
world our conferences are on
lots of things about uh um
the way the field is is organized so
there are lots of things to think about
to make it uh
to keep it healthy and dynamic and
wonderful as
it has been so far i think it's
extremely important to just
you know uh look at what was done
especially in areas you don't know so
well and internalize
not just the technical value but the
meaning and the conceptual value of this
work
and then use it in education i'd say
that that's the main message of my
my talk it's very important in in
courses to describe history to describe
flow of ideas to describe motivation
to describe impact besides
you know besides giving the proofs that
you know
the algorithm hands in an organ time
so anyway uh of course this is a
celebration so let me end in a
happy note happy anniversary field
thank you
thank you very nice great talk um
also very inspiring we have a chance for
some questions so we have about
15 minutes or as long as you want to
take really for questions um
should i stop there stop the sharing
maybe
yes you can saw the sharing yeah i'm
going to switch back to
um so we'll have some questions here if
people like we can go to gather town
afterwards
someone have to post a link in the
window because i don't
have it readily available for the group
but anyway
please either unmute yourself and ask
questions or
type them into the chat window and i'll
read them for you
and in the meantime antonina just posted
a gather town
link to i guess all panelists attendees
i don't know if that
is accessible except to simon's
institute members though
so awesome but yeah
also if anybody wants to ask nobody just
go ahead
but sam you can i cannot uh let me not
go into the chat you can tell me if
somebody
okay and the other comment was if anyone
wants to be um
promoted from attendee to panelist
either oh meet or i
if omed is still here can can do that
for you um
so while we're waiting for people to
come in with questions um
let me start off with we don't have any
in the chat window yet so please
please post some but let me just start
off with something very early in your
talk you asked are there
hard problems at all i think was your
exact quote
and uh of course there's things like the
halting problem i was wondering
if you could clarify more what you what
you mean by that and
so what i mean by that is things that
things that we think yeah so so of
course we know
about that also monotone low bounce and
yeah so when i said any i mean any of
the ones we don't know but uh
to make it more concrete on let's say on
general models of computation we don't
have a single uh super linear low bound
for any problem
for any problem in np just or in
exponential time we don't have super low
bounce right
and eat we don't have uh so it's it's
just striking i mean it's
just what's going on i mean i uh you
know i can say personally
that you know maybe 40 years i've been
thinking about
ways of trying to do it and there are
people here you know in the audience
that have you know
similarly devoted the decades to
thinking about this trying uh all sorts
of approaches and
i think the fact that we don't know this
i mean uh
again says something fundamental of
course we know in mathematics
uh and that's i think the frame of mind
that we should
think of we should have there are
problems that
took decades or so so i think one
certain explanation is that we are far
from having developed the techniques to
deal with the
uh this kind of problems it's just uh
we don't uh that well i could save many
many uh problems about space complexity
about communication complexities
um but yeah you can stick with time and
size that's when
uh maybe the easiest we seem to be
uh totally lacking uh you know
we don't know that p is different than l
right we don't know that
yeah uh we can separate logarithmic
space for polynomial time
and uh or uh np from p space
or p for p space i mean it's just uh
i would say we don't know anything
although we know
a lot so uh uh i think the question of
whether there are hard questions
how problems at all is is a valid one i
mean it's uh
we have a pathetic state of
understanding of law
yeah yeah just to to echo what you say
i'm in a math in in a math department
and my colleagues occasionally ask me
what's going on in the field and i'll
tell them our state of ignorance is
completely profound
right we don't have super linear lower
bounds for concrete problems
we don't have super linear lower bounds
for circuit size and proof complexity
the only lower bounds for systems like
fragos quad quad
quadratic because you have to mention
all the sub formulas and the formula
you're proving
and it's just we are utterly ignorant in
many ways but as you said of course they
made huge progress as well
yeah so it's uh yeah it says something
it's really
fundamental these are hard problems they
are
not not you know i don't see any
difference from the women hypothesis
there are fundamental problems if they
are
prime you know uh objects these are
prime numbers uh our prime objects are
you know circuit types
[Music]
oops okay sorry we have a
okay right here okay all right
um let me see so let's open hopefully
some people will ask some questions here
let's open the floor
to other questions uh oh ito has raised
his hand you know you want to
talk
you know two people raised their hand
let me see how this works
if you've raised your hand let's start
with ido are you able to speak are you
a panelist or should i upgrade you
oh i see there's an attendee with a
raised hand here
um i i figure out how to do this i think
maria also raised her hand
hello can you hear me yes um
oh hi yes so um thanks for this uh
talk uh my question is uh is
this you you have uh described
uh your your wish to separate
uh theory of computing as
a discipline from mathematics of course
it is uh
it is quite different than application
but
how would you say you characterize the
difference between the theory of
computing
and mathematics as two different fields
what is
what is the difference the inherent
difference between them and how would
you explain it to other people
there is no different no i don't
i i have i am extremely comfortable with
this police personality or identity
crisis i think of myself as a computer
science and mathematician
with no problem but what like
the differences between topology and
geometry and analysis and algebra
uh each of them has a
type of objects that they are studying
and type of goals that are very
different from each other
our charge is understanding computation
and as a there is no problem whatsoever
to think of this or
serious computing as a subfield of
mathematics
but but again i just want to say
but again uh unlike many fields of
mathematics
we are connected inspired and
motivated by computational models that
arising from
computer science applications or biology
applications or physics applications
i think that we are an independent field
it's not like to reject anything else we
are connected to all these other fields
and certainly mathematics inspires
our way of work we prove theorems
but uh i think what i think it's really
important that we
separate ourselves in the way we operate
in the
connection between us between the
different sub-disciplines of cof
computation
i think it's very important that we
recognize that
studying algorithms and complexity is a
large enough field as it is of course
you can it's fine if you want to think
of it as also a sub branch of
mathematics
or also the sub runs of computer science
and soon
maybe the sub branch of biology but it's
not
we are separate
okay yes okay
thank you
see we had another hand raised of could
you speak up if possible
who was it i missed otherwise
um well i think there's a question in
the
the chat window at least i'll just read
it i guess thomas kochman asks
to the question whether theory is in the
center of all
is it maybe the underlying idea that any
abstract mathematical understanding is
based on computational algorithms in our
brains okay
it's like yeah that's a good yeah so
first of all in another talk that i gave
i
i mentioned that uh anybody with a
even my limited knowledge of powerpoint
can put anything in the center of the
universe
and i chose to put us in the center of
the universe
and yeah i think that but but i
completely agree i think that the
algorithm or computation
are you know is essential parts
of uh things that go on in nature
things that go on in our brain uh
practically anything that is not totally
stagnant and doesn't move
uh has an algorithmic component in it
i think that the message that physicists
and biologists should integrate
uh algorithmic thinking resource
counting
you know precise resource counting um
just testing the feasibility of a
scientific theory
has to be partly its predictability and
predictability
you know is something that you can
compute
this is a computation so not just your
description of nature is computational
but your model should be computational
and if what your model if the
predictions of your model
are too complex to compute the exact
exponential time something is wrong with
the model
i don't believe that nature is like that
and also what's the value of uh
having a model where you cannot and when
i say exponential
times can be a completely different
measure when you are studying the brain
you have to make sure that this you know
i guess the heat
dissipated inside your skull and you
know the
memory that no one can hold all this
should play into account
you cannot just say you know oh we the
way we remember
uh to to say the digits backwards is
because of blood
you have to support it by some
algorithmic model
and resources and yeah like valiant has
done in the circuits of the mind
it's not to mean that this model is
correct
this is a style of model that should be
adopted that accounts for the
algorithmic parts the resources and so
on
all right so um thank you for
for a great talk avi and i do agree with
with the way you put it just now
which is that computation can be like a
constraint
on how physicist model phenomena for
example
or how scientists model phenomena but i
had another question with regard to
you focus mostly on lower bounds and
i was thinking about parameterized
complexity so we are
able to solve um clauses of instances
for example in the case of say sat
quite quickly and we still don't have a
proper characterization
of these classes of instances on the
other hand
there have been there's been a lot of
work in parameterized complexity
uh which is where they've proven um good
upper bounds
under parameterization so i was
wondering whether you had any comment
about that
sure yeah i mean i can speak about this
for an hour
yeah i figured it it was a great insight
like many insights that there's a
you know often another parameter that
governs the
uh complexity uh besides input size and
it's been used in in lots of works
parameterized complexity is one
excellent example it's not the only
example so
uh dick talks quite a bit about i think
somebody asked him about the question of
uh
[Music]
structure of problems or structure of
inputs to problems that make it easy
uh in some cases even though we believe
they are hard in general so i think
pursuing these revenues
is of course bread and butter and
we have been doing it and there's a lot
more that should be done he mentioned
the book by tim rough garden that
has surveys on various aspects of this
that
works that have done and of course
everybody knows about
deep learning i mean here's a class of
algorithms that is doing wonders
on problems that should be difficult
like me some
non-convex optimization problems and
obviously they are solving again the
easy
instances but what are the easy
instances so
we are you agree i focused on low
bouncing
maybe computational complexity the
algorithmic side which is the flip side
which is
you know as i said they are very well
connected uh
is extremely important and understanding
for which problems important problems
which parameters or what
characterizes easy
easy instances maybe more generally
having
an instance based complexity theory that
will
explain not just not worst case not
average case but the complexity of every
instance
in some sense whatever it is i'm sure
lots of you can do it
so yeah these are great questions there
we have and we have so many
good okay uh there's another question
the chat window of maria paola bone
china asks
uh my question is dual to edo's why
isn't the theory of computation
a subset of computer science so in a
sense it has already been answered
however i think the theory of
computation
is a subset of computer science and i
remain of this of opinion
thanks for the talk so yeah no so i
think yeah yeah answer this we are we
are a part of a lot and we uh
talk to a lot but i think just the study
of the intrinsic
study of computation is a field
right it's it says it has so much in
common and learns so much from so many
other fields but it's a field of his own
it's not in the service of anything it
will serve everything it will serve all
of them
but it's not a servant to any of them
okay uh let's see uh jakob
uh norrister has a question uh jacob do
you want to
a mutant stated or i can do it for you
i'll do it okay he writes connected to
the topic of the simon sapps semester
if we really want to understand
efficient computation including sat
solving
how do we need do we need to go beyond
worst case
how well of course we have to go beyond
worst case and the question of how is a
great uh question i think that it's it's
it's
the remarkable success of that solving
this is now for i don't know
decades uh solving huge uh
systems like in qualification and so on
is is stunning and i think
understanding what is a special
structure uh
that allows this is a fundamental
question
because maybe it will allow solving more
and other problems
of course there are some understandings
there are lots of you know
short implications uh you know you know
which
you know everywhere anyway i'm sure you
guys know much more about this
than me but uh yeah i think that uh
understanding in this particular example
i mean i don't think
sat is great and it's a it's a great uh
thing to reduce uh uh other problems too
but it's not the only one there are lots
of
like dick mentioned the linear
programming uh
or even integer programming where in
many cases
you have uh fast solutions and again the
problems solved by deep learning
learning are also you know seemingly
difficult so
i i wish i knew how to
how to build a theory that's missing
and but i think the way we are going
about solving this type of problems and
the fact that we are taking them on is
the beginning of another success
all right well on that note we should
probably
end up thank you again so much for the
fabulous talk uh to both you and dick in
fact so and thanks
again i'll pretend to clap on behalf of
everybody
and uh so those of you who are simon's
uh participants can go to the gather
town link i'm afraid we don't have any
way to accommodate people who aren't
participants so but
so you can also hang out here for a few
minutes if you want to talk as well
but otherwise uh thank you again to
everybody okay thank you sam thanks
everybody
all right
you